in just a few days now catholic
charities of southern nevada will mark
80
years of service to those most in need
in our community and in commemoration
they're cooking up a feast chefs are
preparing for the big day right now
hector mejia is live there trying very
hard to stay out of the way and
try not to eat all the chicken already
hector's there live good morning hector
good morning guys and we're wishing
catholic charities of southern nevada
this morning
a very happy birthday and we're in the
kitchen as we've been showing you all
morning long
this is just one of many
cakes they have out here that they're
making and here we have chef kendra with
the cream cheese
getting ready for this carrot cake and
they're just getting
all prepared for friday friday is a big
day as they celebrate 80 years here in
her valley
we're going to talk with leslie she's
going to tell us about not just the
activity that's going on right now
but also how are we all preparing for
friday happy birthday
thank you um
you yeah look 80. thank goodness
um well we doing like a big meal like
what we're getting used to
getting ready to do for friday it takes
a lot of preparation so we kind of
started a couple months ago talking
about the menu and what we're going to
do
and how we can celebrate with our
clients so we're going to be giving
everybody a t-shirt as well on friday so
we're really excited to be able to do
that and that our community is helping
us do this
and a lot is happening right now i want
to share with you guys just a few
minutes ago
that giant tub of gravy
was overflowing earlier and what
happened
our kitchen team is always ready she was
getting ready to mix it and we were
talking and then it started bowling over
she ran over and got it
and she saved it you guys weren't able
to see it it happened live during her
hit
but they were playing video and you just
couldn't see the action just a
really gravy exploding that was awesome
i've never seen that before
it's all fun let's talk about also
volunteer opportunities people can also
help out you guys are seeing a big need
and the big thing is you know helping
out people while having fun
and treating people with dignity as well
yeah this year was a little bit
different
this year and last year we were able we
had to kind of postpone our in-person
volunteer activities but we've created
some
ways that people can help from home and
still make a really lasting impact for
the clients that are coming to us for
help
and lastly before we let everyone go
tell us about the details for friday for
those who are interested in celebrating
a happy birthday with you guys
yeah catholic charities 80th anniversary
we're doing a special meal for our
clients at 10 a.m in the outdoor
pavilion and all are welcome
all right thank you very much so where
did the cake go so we have one
sheet right here and we're just going to
walk just
five feet right here so i can show you
we're telling you they're making a lot
of cake and this is all for friday
and again happy birthday to catholic
charities of southern nevada
as they celebrate 80 long years here
in her valley reporting live hector
mejia 8 news now back to you guys
hector thank you very much of course
that food going to a great cause the
valley is homeless people who are
struggling we know so many people are
having a hard time right now
they do a lot of great work over there
and hector hopefully that explosion of
gravy wasn't your fault
hector you're doing good work out there
as always thank you